The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today I want
to start us off on a
somewhat new topic.
Which is phase equilibria.
So, recently you've been
looking at chemical
equilibria.
What happens when substances
change their chemical
structure and interchange, and
you've figured out how to
calculate where equilibrium
lies in the
case of chemical reactions.
Calculate equilibrium constants,
and so forth.
Now we'll introduce
phase equilibria.
So this is a little
bit different.
You still have a lot of
molecules in one state
changing to another state, but
they're not changing their own
molecular structure.
They're changing what phase
of matter they're in.
From liquid to solid to gas.
And so the treatment is a
little bit different.
And there's some new results
that are somewhat different
from what you've seen in the
case of chemical reactions.
So we'll start with phase
equilibria in just one
component system.
So in other words, we're going
to start with a single
substance and see how it goes
from solid to liquid to gas.
And we'll from there
see what happens in
multiple component systems.
Where, for example, then we'll
be able to talk about
solubility and mixtures of
liquids and so forth.
And into which phase different
constituents in a
mixture will go.
But let's start here.
So, let's say we just have two
phases at equilibrium.
And this could just look
like ice and water.
You could have a little bit
of ice floating in water.
So in this case you have
solid and liquid.
That could be in equilibrium.
And this is going to be at some
pressure and temperature.
Or, you could have liquid
and gas in equilibrium.
So let's put a lid
on our container.
Still have some specified
pressure and temperature.
And now there's a liquid
at the bottom.
And a gas at the top.
So, you could have equilibrium
between liquid and gas phases.
And in some cases you have
equilibrium between solid and
gas phases, depending
on the pressure.
And and a little piece of solid
could sit at the bottom
and there's equilibrium
with the gas above it.
And so, to start, what quantity
are we going to need
to look at to tell whether the
different phases are in
equilibrium, or if they're not
in equilibrium, in which
direction are things
going to go?
Are things going to change so
that the ice will melt and
we'll have water or, so
the water will freeze
and we'll have ice.
What quantity is going to
tell us about all that?
Who thinks they can guess?
Give you a hint.
We're specifying pressure
and temperature.
Nobody really knows?
What quantity is it that you've
seen from which you can
determine everything.
Yes.
The Gibbs free energy is going
to tell us everything.
And we're going to frame the
discussion in terms of the
chemical potential.
That is, the Gibbs free
energy for a mole.
And since there's only one
constituent, one component at
this point, we just have n.
We don't have different mole
numbers for different
constituents, we'll
see that later.
OK, so what's going to happen
is, the value of the chemical
potential in the different
phases is going to tell us
everything.
Because you know that at
equilibrium, the chemical
potential needs to be the
same in all of these.
If not, let's say the potential
energy here is lower
in the solid than in the gas,
nothing's going to stop the
molecules in the gas
phase from going
into the solid phase.
That's what they'll do.
If the chemical potential of
the water is lower than the
chemical potential of the ice,
then the ice is going to melt.
Because the molecules are going
to want to go toward
lowest possible accessible
chemical potential.
And there's the liquid
right there.
They have access to it, so they
can, the ice will melt.
And you'll have just water.
So the main point here is that
at equilibrium, mu is
identical everywhere.
By everywhere, I mean in
all phases that are at
equilibrium.
And so if multiple phases are
present, mu has to be the same
in all the phases.
And if it isn't, then the
molecules will go into the
phase with the lower
chemical potential.
And this is what is going to
guide everything in our
consideration of phase
equilibrium.
So, OK, what's going
to happen?
Let's consider our ice
water equilibrium.
So of course, if mu of the solid
is equal to mu of the
liquid, which for water it
should happen at zero degrees
Centigrade.
And pressure of one bar, for
example, not the only place it
could happen.
But certainly at
that condition.
Then the ice and water
will be in
equilibrium, they'll co-exist.
Now, what happens if you just
want some ice water and you
take some ice out of the freezer
and put it in the cup,
and you put some water in?
And you see them both there.
They're sitting there.
Maybe for a while.
And yet it's not
at zero degrees
Centigrade, at one bar.
It may be at one bar, you might
be out in the room, but
it might be room temperature.
Does that tell us that
this isn't true?
What's going to happen?
The ice is going to melt.
It may take a while.
This doesn't tell us about
the kinetics of it.
And it could take a while,
gradually, from the surface
inward, for the ice to melt.
So the fact that you might see
something sitting there with
two phases present, that alone
of course, doesn't tell you
the two phases are
in equilibrium.
And it may take time for
equilibrium to occur.
And what's going to happen
if at some pressure and
temperature, you have the mu s
greater than mu of the liquid.
Then which way are things
going to go?
What's going to happen?
You've got to be able
to figure this out.
Of course.
The ice is going to melt.
The chemical potential of
the liquid is lower.
And so molecules are going to
move toward that phase.
And, of course, if mu solid less
than mu liquid, then the
water freezes.
All this behavior is something
that we can summarize in a
phase diagram.
So the phase diagram can tell
us for all pressures and
temperatures, what phase, or
what phases, will be present
in equilibrium.
And so typically, phase diagram
might look like this.
Where here's our solid.
Here's our liquid.
Here's our gas phase.
So let's just look at what's
happening here.
If we go to really low
temperature, in
general, what happens?
What phase does stuff enter
when you're at the lowest
accessible temperatures?
Solid, right?
Everything eventually freezes.
In fact, really I should make
this, leave some room on my
axis for that effect.
So of course, low temperature
you get solid.
How about high pressure,
what usually happens?
You squeeze something
real hard.
Tends to go into the
solid phase.
Now let's warm stuff up.
And depending on the pressure,
you might go
to the liquid phase.
Certainly you'll go to the
gas phase at high enough
temperature.
And that's what'll happen.
And now, if you start changing
the pressure, let's say you're
at high temperature and you've
got just the gas present, in
some big container.
Now you start squeezing it.
You just apply more and more
pressure to the gas at
constant temperature.
What's going to happen?
Forget the phase diagram.
You know what's going
to happen.
You keep squeezing, what
will happen eventually?
This isn't going to be
part of your grade.
You can speak up loud, and
even if you're completely
wrong, nothing bad is going
to happen to you.
Yeah.
It's going to liquefy,
of course.
You're going to start getting
liquid to form.
It's essentially Le Chatelier's
principle, of course.
The liquid occupies
less volume.
The density of the liquid
is much higher.
So as you increase the pressure,
the stuff wants to
go from the gas phase
to the liquid phase.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, with water
you know that at ordinary
pressure, you know where
the gas-liquid
coexistence would occur.
So let's say you're there.
Let's say you're at
the boiling point.
And now, you already in some
sense know that that's a point
that's somewhere on the
gas-liquid curve.
So now what's going to happen?
Well, if you from there keep
that temperature constant.
You're at the boiling point.
And you could easily do this.
You've got a pot that's
covered, right?
And it's boiling.
So there's liquid down here
and there's gas here.
So what'll happen?
As you start squeezing,
literally what'll happen is
you'll squeeze out all
the room for the gas.
And eventually you'll
have all liquid.
And in fact, you know what'll
happen at that point, if you
keep squeezing and you
keep the heat on.
The liquid will get hotter
than the boiling point.
Normally that doesn't happen,
if you're just out at
atmospheric pressure.
Because it'll boil.
And instead of getting hotter,
molecules will simply leave
the liquid and go into
the gas phase.
So that's what'll happen.
If you increase the pressure,
you'll liquefy all the gas.
And obviously the opposite
will also occur.
If you just allow the volume to
expand and keep expanding,
maybe you don't have too much
liquid there, you wouldn't
have to expand it too much.
You'll run out, all the
liquid will vaporize.
And you'll just have gas at 100
degrees C. You could heat
it more if you wanted,
but even there.
So in other words, changing
the pressure if you think
about actually executing that
in the lab, or in this case
even in your kitchen, you'll get
the result that you should
see on the phase diagram.
So let's just look at this.
So we've already talked
about boiling.
That's what's happening
along this line.
The line, and I'll explain the
end of this in a while, all
these lines are coexistence
curves.
That is, these are
where you have
equilibrium between two phases.
They coexist in equilibrium. and
it could happen for water,
for that case, for 100 degrees
C and one bar.
But that's not the only place.
It could happen it
a whole bunch of
temperatures and pressure.
Because as you vary the
pressure, you're almost surely
familiar with this, the
boiling point changes.
So the boiling point up in
Denver at high elevation is
not the same as the boiling
point here in Massachusetts
right at sea level.
Because the pressure's
lower up in Denver.
Let's just look at the others.
So, of course, this is going
from solid to liquid.
So we're looking at melting.
And then there is solid-gas
equilibria in many cases.
And this is sublimation.
And this endpoint is called
the critical point.
And there's one point where
all three phases are in
equilibrium, called
the triple point.
So let's look at the
various cases.
For example, let's look
at the melting line.
It could be water, it could
be water and ice.
Solid going to a liquid.
Let's just look at them
one at a time.
What you have there is mu of the
solid at some temperature
and pressure.
Is equal to mu of the
liquid at the same
temperature and pressure.
Now, just if we back off and
look at this essentially
mathematically, there's
an equation here.
And there are two
free variables.
Temperature and pressure.
The equation puts a constraint
on them.
So there are going to be a bunch
of solutions along some
line or some curve.
So in other words, it's one
equation in two unknowns.
Temperature and pressure.
So the solution is a
line or a curve.
In other words, we could solve
for pressure as a function of
temperature, or temperatures
as a function of pressure,
along the coexistence curve.
And we'll do that shortly.
Now, if we're in one of these
regions, then there aren't any
equalities.
There aren't any constraints.
Because we don't have multiple
chemical potentials that are
equal to each other.
Right here we have three
phases in chemical
equilibrium.
Solid, liquid and gas.
So let's just look at
that triple point.
Mu solid equals mu liquid
equals mu of the gas.
We have two unknowns,
or two variables,
temperature and pressure.
And we have two equations.
What that means is there's only
one solution, and that's
what the phase diagram shows.
There's a unique solution, the
triple point temperature and
the triple point pressure.
So this has only one solution.
If we summarize, how many
degrees of freedom, or how
many free variables, we have,
anywhere here, we can do that
in the following way.
We can write F is 3 minus p.
This is the number of
degrees of freedom.
Or independent variables.
And this is the number of
phases in equilibrium.
So, what's it telling us?
If we have just one phase in
equilibrium, or way over in
the solid or just gas
or just liquid part
of the phase diagram.
This is one.
We have two independent
variables.
Which is exactly what we
know to be the case.
In other words, in those
regions, temperature and
pressure can vary freely
without constraints.
If we go to any of the
coexistence curves, now we
have two phases in
equilibrium.
And then only one variable
can be changed freely.
If we want to stay on the
coexistence curve, let's say
we've got gas and liquid
in equilibrium.
It's boiling.
We could change the pressure
some, but if we want to keep
them in equilibrium, if we've
changed the pressure, we'd
better change the temperature
accordingly to stay on the
coexistence curve.
Otherwise everything will
go up into the liquid or
into the gas phase.
Because you'll go off of the
coexistence curve if you were
to change one of these variables
and not the other.
In other words, there's
a constraint.
So only one can vary freely.
And if all three phases are in
equilibrium at the triple
point, then you have no
degrees of freedom.
Nothing can vary and
there's only one
place where that happens.
Now let's see if we can
understand also, why does the
whole thing have the overall
structure that it does.
Why are some of the slopes
generally steeper than others.
Turns out, we can get a
qualitative understanding of
phase equilibria in a
pretty simple way.
So in other words, can we
understand how p and T change
with respect to each other
along any one of these
coexistence curves?
Can we understand the
qualitative features of the
phase diagrams?
And what we'll see is, we can
get an equation for dp/dT at
coexistence.
That's, in a sense, our
objective here in order to get
the sort of qualitative
picture.
So let's say we are
somewhere here.
It could be the gas-solid
part.
And we have some T. And now we
go to T plus dT, and out here
is pressure.
How much does the pressure
change when we stay on the
coexistence curve?
Well, let's go through this.
Let's just consider any two
phases, alpha and beta.
They could be solid,
liquid, gas.
And the main condition, if
we're going to be on the
coexistence curve, is
that the chemical
potentials have to be equal.
Well, that's fine.
Now let's change the conditions
a little bit.
Staying on the coexistence
curve.
So, let's start again. mu s,
or mu alpha of T and p is
equal to mu beta at T and p.
Now let's let temperature go to
T plus dT, and pressure go
to p plus dp.
But since we're staying on the
coexistence curve still, at
the new temperature and
pressure, mu alpha and beta
have to be equal
to each other.
So mu alpha is going to go to
mu alpha plus d mu alpha.
There'll be some change in it.
Mu beta is going to go to
mu beta plus d mu beta.
But we already have that mu
alpha and mu beta at the
beginning were equal
to each other.
And these have to be equal
Because we've specified that
we're staying on the
coexistence curve.
So what that says is d mu
alpha equals d mu beta.
And now, remember in general
d mu is dG per mole, so our
fundamental equation for G, it's
minus S per mole dT plus
molar volume dp.
So this equality is telling us
that minus S alpha dT plus V
alpha dp is equal to minus
S beta dT plus V beta dp.
So we're just applying the
fundamental relation to the
changes in each of the phases.
But since the changes
in mu are equal,
so are these changes.
And now I'm just going
to rearrange these.
In other words, S beta minus S
alpha dT is equal to V theta
minus V alpha dp.
And that immediately
is going to give us
our derivative dp/dT.
So, dp/dT, staying the
coexistence curve, is just S
beta minus S alpha over
V beta minus V alpha.
Which is to say it's just, we
can say delta S over delta V.
Going from alpha to beta.
So we have a result that can
guide our thinking into what
the slopes of those
coexistence lines
are going to be.
And it's pretty useful
to look at that.
By the way, we can actually
express this in
another way if we want.
And in some cases it can
be advantageous.
And that is, we know that of
course G is H minus TS.
So our mu alpha equals mu beta
condition, or a d mu alpha is
d mu beta condition, can
be applied that way.
That is, H alpha minus
TS alpha equals H
beta minus TS beta.
So we can do the same
rearrangements.
H beta minus H alpha equals
T S beta minus S alpha.
And what that's saying, in other
words, is that we can
substitute for delta S, delta H
over T. So we can write our
relation for dp/dT
in two ways.
We can also write dp/dT at
coexistence is equal to delta
H over T delta V. Going
from alpha to beta.
These are both forms of what's
called the Clapeyron equation.
And these are always valid.
We haven't made any
approximations.
Yet.
Later, in going to the gas
phase, we'll make some
approximations about having
an ideal gas.
We'll be able to treat this
delta V in a simple way using
the ideal gas law.
But for now, these are exact.
OK, so now let's look
at what it tells us.
Let's look at the different
pieces of the phase diagram
and see what we can conclude.
Essentially we should be able
to construct qualitatively,
the features of the phase
diagram using this relation.
So let's try to do that.
Here's p and T. We're going to
start with an empty slate.
And now let's look at
the liquid gas case.
So, let's look at our delta
S delta V, going
from liquid to gas.
Well, one thing you know, when
you go from liquid to gas,
what happens to the
molar volume?
It increases.
By a little, by a lot?
By a lot, right?
The molar volume in the gas is
enormous compared to the molar
volume in the liquid.
So delta V is positive
and very big.
Now let's think about delta S.
What's it going to do, going
from liquid to gas?
It's going to increase?
The disorder increases.
Now, it increases
significantly.
But the liquid already is
a disordered phase.
And the molecules and the
liquid already have
considerable freedom.
Certainly not near as much as
they have in the gas phase.
But still considerable.
So, to be sure, delta
S positive.
And it's not small.
So there's your condition.
It's not nearly as big
as delta V is going
to turn out to be.
So what's going to happen here
is, if we look at the slope
going from liquid to
gas, it's positive.
But it's not enormous.
It's not very steep.
So dp/dT, for liquid-gas
coexistence right, greater
than zero, but small.
Not steep slope.
So somewhere, we're going to
put our liquid-gas curve.
And I, where exactly we
can worry about it.
We haven't put any numbers
on this scale.
But the point is, wherever it
is, it's not going to be a
very steep slope.
How about solid to gas?
Well, so what's delta V going
from the solid to the gas?
What happens to the
molar volume?
What happens to the molar
volume, going from solid?
Of course, by a lot,
by a little?
By a lot.
It's an enormous increase.
Even bigger than before.
How about delta S, the
entropy change?
Yeah, it increases.
And also by a lot, because now
you're going from an ordered
crystalline solid, usually, so
you have a very, very, low
entropy there.
Into a disordered phase.
Not just the liquid,
but the gas phase.
So this is also very big.
Well, ok, so now we've got delta
S over delta V. There's
going to be a steeper slope.
Because this is bigger then
for liquid to gas.
So typically, the solid-liquid
part will have a steeper slope
then the liquid to gas part.
Now, wait.
Sorry, sorry, this
isn't right.
And that's because I've really
badly misplaced things here.
That was solid to gas that
we just discussed.
It has the steepest slope
relative to liquid-gas.
OK, now let's think about
solid to liquid.
Delta V for going from
solid to a liquid.
What is it?
What sign is it?
How big is it?
Let's forgot about the
sign for a minute.
How much does the volume, molar
volume, change going
from solid to liquid?
Yeah, not a very lot, right?
You melt the solid.
There's still a little piece
of stuff down there.
Didn't increase in volume
enormously.
Usually, it increases.
So generally delta V is
greater than, or sort
of equal to, zero.
It's not a big amount.
How about entropy?
Going from solid to liquid?
It increases, by
a good amount.
You're going from an ordered
to a disordered phase.
So delta S is greater
than zero.
And so the result here is, now,
if you look at dS/dV, or
delta S over delta V, delta S
is positive and you a pretty
good amount.
Delta V is small.
The molar volume
hardly changed.
And so what that's going to tell
us is the slope is going
to be steep.
And generally positive.
So now, we're going to really
be on the increase.
Typical kind of phase
diagram and
individual coexistence curve.
And all these things, again, you
could understand in terms
of Le Chatelier's principle.
In terms of going from, say,
solid to liquid if you know
think about two pressures.
Go from p1 to p2, some
higher pressure.
Where are you?
Well, if you want to stay on the
coexistence curve you need
to raise the temperature quite
a bit in order to do that.
Because, basically, to keep on
there, you know what's going
to happen if you have, say,
solid and liquid.
It's ice and water.
You know the freezing point,
it does depend on the
pressure, of course.
But since the change in the
volume isn't that big, what
happens is, a modest change, if
you change the temperature
by a little bit, maybe easier
to think about it that way,
you've got to change the
pressure by a lot to stay on
the coexistence curve.
Otherwise it'll have a great
tendency to simply go into one
phase or the other.
Now we've, in a sense,
reconstructed the coexistence
curve by our consideration of
the Clapeyron equation.
There's another way we can
usefully understand the
qualitative features of
the phase diagram.
And that's just by looking
at mu itself.
Looking at the free energy
itself, at different
temperature.
So let's just do that.
Let's just consider mu of T
at some fixed pressure.
Just qualitatively,
what will happen?
So let's go back to d mu is
minus S dT plus V dp.
And just look at the
derivatives.
So d mu / dT at constant
pressure is minus s.
Minus the molar volume.
This is the one we're really
going to look at.
Of course, we also could look
at d mu / dp at constant
temperature, and just
the molar volume.
Let's just look at this.
We know that entropy is always
a positive number, right?
Entropy at the lowest, in a
perfect crystal, at zero
Kelvin, could be what value?
Entropy of a perfect
pure crystal at
zero degrees Kelvin.
Zero, right?
And it's only going
up from there.
So entropy is always positive.
So what that tells us is that,
then, if we just look at mu
versus T, it's negative
S, for whatever phase.
So it's always negative.
So in some sense, you say why?
Well, it's because we're keeping
pressure constant and
we're raising the temperature
and essentially the effect of
the entropy is more important.
Is going up.
You could see it just by saying
well, G is H minus TS.
And as you raise temperature,
the product TS is increasing.
Which means the G is
decreasing, because
it's H minus TS.
So it's always a
negative slope.
Let's look at it in the
different phases.
So we have entropy of the gas,
that's greater than the
entropy of the liquid.
Which is greater than the
entropy of the solid.
So that immediately tells us
the relative slopes for the
three phases.
So d mu gas / dT at constant
pressure is minus S gas. d mu
liquid / dT is minus S of the
liquid. d mu solid / dT is
minus S of the solid.
And the magnitude is much bigger
in the gas than the
liquid than the solid.
And so the same goes
for the slope.
So now let's sketch this.
There's mu.
And there's temperature.
So what we've seen is for the
gas, first of all, the slope's
always negative.
And it's steepest by
far, or steepest
substantially, for the gas.
Next steepest for the liquid.
And least steep of all
for the solid.
Now, there can be variation.
Because, of course,
these do change as
a function of pressure.
But this, certainly the slope,
the magnitudes of the slopes
are always going to
be like this.
What could change as a function
of pressure is where
these happen to lie.
But this is certainly typical.
So what does it mean?
So, it means, remember, the
stuff is always going to be in
the phase with the lowest
value of mu.
So at low temperature, down
here, that's where the solid
phase has the lowest
chemical potential.
Now, let's keep going up.
Eventually they cross.
This is where, for this
particular pressure, this is
where the liquid and the solid
are in equilibrium.
In other words, we've started,
we've got the solid and we're
raising the pressure.
Now it's going to melt.
Here's our melting point at
this particular pressure.
And now we've got, if we keep
raising the temperature, we're
no longer in equilibrium, and
we'll be in the one phase part
of the phase diagram.
It's just the liquid.
Because that's the lowest
chemical potential.
Let's keep raising
the temperature.
Down here, of course, the
chemical potential of the gas
is way up there, right?
So it's not going to come into
play now, though they're going
to be in equilibrium.
Here is the boiling point.
So now let's keep raising
the temperature.
And we'll be in just the
gas part of the curve.
And of course that'll
go on forever.
So that can just help us
understand, in addition to the
slopes, the positions, the
relative positions, of where
these equilibria occur.
Now if we start changing the
pressure in particular, we
could move this.
So that you could have a
sublimation point where the
gas and the solid are in
equilibrium because this has
moved over to here.
Any questions about the overall
structure of the phase
diagrams and these
phase equilibria?
OK, let me just end with a few
comments about one part of the
phase diagram that we haven't
talked about yet.
This.
What's going on there?
If we were to change, of course,
I've got a finite
amount of space on the
blackboard, so I haven't drawn
T and p out to infinity.
But if I could, this line would
keep going forever.
There would always be some
pressure and temperature at
which you would have equilibrium
between two
different, distinct solid
and liquid phases.
Turns out, that's not true for
the gas and the liquid.
And there are a bunch
of ways to see this.
But one is you could think of
the symmetry difference.
When you go from a crystal, a
crystal and solid, to a liquid
or a gas, there's no question
that you've changed phase.
Because there's a symmetry in
the solid that's no longer
maintained in the isotropic
liquid or gas.
So clearly there's never going
to be a point where these two
phases become the same thing.
Become somehow
indistinguishable.
But the gas and the liquid,
I don't know, what's the
difference between them?
The density, right?
The gas is more dense.
It's condensed.
Sorry, the liquid
is condensed.
The gas isn't.
But that starts to change when
you adjust the pressure and
temperature accordingly.
And you can sort of
see it coming.
What'll happen is, you change
the temperature, the molar
volumes of the liquid and
the gas start to get
equal to each other.
That's what'll end
up happening.
And at that point, what's the
difference between them?
There is no difference.
There's no symmetry
difference.
So you can actually, instead
of going through a phase
transition, where there's a
meniscus, you can see the top
of the liquid when
you heat it up.
There's boiling and then
there's the gas.
You can actually go from the
gas, let's go the other way,
from the liquid to the gas
phase, without ever boiling.
If you change the pressure
as well.
So that you can actually walk
all the way around the
critical point.
What happens, is up here you
don't have two distinguishable
phases any more.
And actually, material out at
this region has a bunch of
very unusual behaviors.
Very useful behaviors,
actually.
Chemical behavior can be really
very, very, different
in what's called supercritical,
the
supercritical region beyond
the critical point.
Water behaves really
unusually there.
Or it turns out, in that region,
it turns out to be a
terrific solvent for
organic stuff.
Organic molecules which
normally don't
dissolve well in water.
And it doesn't dissolve
salts very well.
That's pretty unusual.
Carbon dioxide, CO2, turns out
to be a pretty good solvent
for organics in the
supercritical region.
That's what dry cleaning is.
Very nice, because know CO2,
apart from its slow effect on
our atmosphere, it's
not poisonous.
It's not toxic.
So you can do dry cleaning
without organic solvents.
All sorts of unusual behavior
happens above
the critical point.
Beyond the critical point.
There's also a whole range
of behavior at
the critical point.
Right at the critical point
that's extremely unusual.
That you could think of as a
consequence of the fact that
the molar volumes are
getting to be almost
equal to each other.
That's unusual in
a lot of ways.
And what ends up happening is,
you can see if you go online,
actually, if you just Google
critical point, you can see
amazing movies of stuff that's
at the critical point.
Because what happens is, so
you've got the liquid.
And you've got a meniscus,
and you've got the gas.
And you can tell.
You look at it.
There's the liquid.
There's the gas.
But if you go real close to the
critical point, the stuff
doesn't really know what
phase it's in.
Because it's losing
the distinction
between the two phases.
You start seeing globules
of liquid up
there in the gas phase.
And globules of the gas
down in the liquid.
Because their densities - I
mean, the only reason the
liquid's at the bottom normally
is because the
density is higher.
If that stops being the case, it
has no more right to occupy
the bottom part than the gas.
And so they sort of start
interchanging.
And if you get even closer,
of course, what eventually
happens is, there's
just one phase.
You don't see distinct
meniscus's any more.
But right near there, you see
enormous fluctuations in the
local density and
in the location.
The physical locations
of different phases.
And we'll see that come in
another context later.
Because when we talk about two
phase equilibria solutions.
You get this with you oil and
water, you get critical
mixtures also, where right
at the special point, the
meniscus goes away and the oil
and water start interchanging.
And in those situations, a tiny
amount of force can give
you a really big response.
Because the two things are just
teetering in the balance.
So a little bit of force
pushes things
one way or the other.
That's actually useful
in a whole bunch
of different cases.
Because that critical behavior
happens in all kinds of phase
transitions.
Magnetic phase transitions.
Ferroelectric phase
transitions.
And in those situations, a tiny
little magnetic field,
for example, gives you a really
big change in the
magnetization.
If the alignment of spins.
And that's very useful.
You can get a very big material
response and change.
You can switch something, for
example, with a really small
external field.
And in these cases, you can
change the density really a
lot by only a small change
in pressure.
OK, next time we'll extend the
Clapeyron equation and also go
to two component systems.
So you actually, Professor
Blendi will take
over again on Friday.
And we'll see you then.